if you've ever seen a film before the
musical score is attached in a place
that looks something like this there's
really no polite way to put this it's
just it's just lies there a movie score
is the electrical charge it's the breath
of life creative suspense and tears what
makes our hearts well the final kiss a
great musical score is so memorable and
so vivid that we will forgive it even as
it chases us years later through malls
and elevators here the nominees for the
best original score' Anna Karenina by
Dario Mari and Ellie
Argo by Alexander Splott Life of Pi by
Michael Dennin Skyfall by Thomas Newman
Lincoln by John Williams and the Oscar
goes to open this up here that is he go
ahead
[Applause]
here for original song for life
[Music]
for win
[Music]
I share this wondrous award with our
visionary captain mr. Angley Terry is
we're playing this game again who guided
a truly global cast and crew in the
telling of this wondrous beautiful story
that transcends culture and race and
religion in the same spirit musicians
from around the globe came together to
breathe life into this music and I hold
this award on their behalf I want to
thank my beautiful Fox family my mom
who's in a balcony here watching my
father who's also watching and most of
all my wife a Poorna and our two
beautiful boys Arjun and Keysha who
remind me every day why stories like
this need to be told thank you everyone
Thank You Academy thank you
[Applause]